hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and with the
recent dark and serious turn in the mha
story we may be finally leading up to
the last big reveal of the entire series
the true identity of deku's Father the
last few chapters have really focused in
on one major aspect of the mha world and
this has given us some major world
building along with some major character
development but with this happening so
late in the game it could all be just a
build up for the big deku's dad reveal
so let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our vids leave a
quick like and comment right now to
support us in that crazy YouTube
algorithm and by the way over half of
you guys who watch our videos are not
subscribed yet the fact that you're
watching this video means that you get
to watch this video but with the way
that YouTube works you really have to
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this in the future so do me a big
favor and take the time time to
subscribe hit that notification Bell and
select the option that says all finally
this video will contain Boku no hero
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned now have
you noticed that most of the biggest
mysteries in mha have just been resolved
in the last few arcs including the
identity of the UA Trader the nature of
deku's final Quirk Dobby's true identity
although literally everyone saw that
coming and we also had some big and
long-awaited face reveals including toru
hagakure and mezzo Shoji but even with
the story in its final stages and
possibly in the very last Arc there is
still one big mystery that hasn't been
resolved even though horikoshi stated in
the past that it would be resolved
before the story is over that mystery is
of course the true identity of deku's
father and why he's been completely
missing from the story this entire time
the recent shift in focus from the major
battles to the issue of discrimination
Nation against heteromorphs also known
as people with mutant type quirks May
hint at a connection between this
important issue and the last great
mystery yet to be revealed in the story
who is deku's Father and where has he
been all this time just to recap a
little bit in the middle of the Epic
final fight between Deku and shigaraki
the manga suddenly shifted gears and yes
pun intended instead of focusing on the
big main fights that are currently
taking place including the shigaraki
fight the all-for-one fight and the
Dobby fight mha chose to give us some
really dark and serious World building
as the discrimination against mutant
type Quirk users was finally explored in
detail with the help of meso Shoji and
his personal life experience the
Discrimination of mutant type Quirk
users has been hinted at before so this
is not completely new to us but
realistically we should have gotten more
information about this sooner Shoji
turned out to be such a fascinating and
inspirational character with a tragic
and compelling backstory and yet we
hardly knew anything about him until the
very last stages of the story that is
kind of a shame in my opinion before
this Shoji was always just kind of a
background character in class 1a and yet
he has so much to offer and so we
learned that even though in big cities
there is more equality and heteromorphs
hold some important positions of power
discrimination is still alive and well
in the countryside and it's showing no
signs of going away the villains who are
currently attacking the hospital believe
that all mutants type Quirk users who
side with the heroes and the hero
Society are spoiled City Slickers who
don't know what their fellow
heteromorphs are going through outside
the big city the previous chapter ended
with Shoji and Koda fighting the
villains to protect the innocent people
at the hospital despite being mutant
type Quirk users themselves and despite
the fact that Shoji is no City Slicker
he actually comes from the country side
and he went through a lot of hardship
and discrimination as others attacked
him as a child for having quote unquote
tainted blood the latest chapter picks
up as Shoji asks spinner whether he's
even considered the safety of the
innocent civilians at the hospital
before he decided to launch this
dangerous attack Shoji also adds that if
the answer is no he will never forgive
spinner and his cronies and this makes
sense to be honest since there are very
likely some innocent heteromorphs at the
hospital as well this means that even if
we accepted the claims of the villains
that they are fighting for the rights
and freedoms of mutant Quirk users their
own actions are not even consistent with
that claim they are actively endangering
fellow heteromorphs as much as every
other person in the area that they're
attacking so who are they really
protecting who are they really fighting
for Shoji's question is a good one and
the other heteromorphs who have been
supporting spinner are now beginning to
pay attention to the conversation they
also noticed that Shoji has some serious
scars on his face scars that make it
clear that he's gone through a lot and
he's not just some pampered City kid the
crowd tells spinner to explain the
righteousness of their cause to Shoji
but spinner has no idea what's going on
and he can't even begin to coherently
answer the question he just looks like a
drugged out Godzilla and the only words
that he can produce are no idea the
crowd is confused by this and the
Paranormal Liberation Front Commander
from the previous chapter tries to save
the situation by claiming that spinner
is saying that normal people have no
idea how much the mutant Quirk users
have suffered this seems to be enough
for the crowd for now but Shoji persists
he tells spinner that this attack is
going to set their cause back by 30
years since innocent people are about to
get hurt and that is going to draw even
more ire and hatred towards heteromorphs
we then learned that spinner actually
received multiple quirks from All For
One including one called durability and
one called scale armor but receiving
these quirks seems to have clouded his
mind somehow probably because of the
fact that he now possesses like three
different quirks but his body didn't
undergo the same procedure as shigarakis
so that means that Spinner's body isn't
able to handle all of those quirks
spinner may actually be turning into
something resembling a living gnomu a
Mindless servant of all for one and if
that is the case then it underscores yet
again the sheer ruthlessness of all for
one he decided to turn spinner into a
Mindless Beast just so he could use him
for one single Mission which is to
rescue kurogiri after that he may
completely dispose of spinner as he has
done with many other people over the
course of his long life span and again
this just showcases very clearly and
blatantly that all for one couldn't care
less about mutant type Quirk users in
fact he may have instigated some of the
attacks on them in the past but we'll
have to wait and see spinner then
proceeds to activate his scale armor
Quirk and his giant body is suddenly
covered in sharp scales now looking even
more like Godzilla spinner attacks Shoji
injuring him in the process and sending
him flying backwards as Coda screams out
in concern the plf commander tries once
again to rally the troops he tells them
that this is the time to strike back at
their oppressors and that the revolution
requires martyrdom according to him the
sacrifices they make today will benefit
the future of all heteromorphs we can't
Overlook just how deceptive and
Insidious the Commander's speech is he
is essentially telling these people that
they must sacrifice their lives for the
revolution but he is refusing to address
Shoji's perfectly legitimate criticisms
of their actions he is also willfully
covering up the fact that spinner is not
all there and that the real leader
behind this movement is actually all for
one I am highly suspicious of this
Commander guy he doesn't seem to be
genuinely interested in his own cause
he's more of a propagandist for All For
One meanwhile Coda thinks back to a time
in the past when the class 1a students
hung out together inside their dorm we
learned that Shoji was in fact
comfortable with taking off his mask in
front of his classmates and he was also
comfortable telling them about his
tragic backstory Shoji's parents didn't
have the kind of arms that he was born
with he was the only one and because
they lived in a small Backwater Village
he faced a lot of discrimination and
abuse his unique physical features were
seen as a sign of quote unquote impure
blood whatever that means and he was
badly hurt and brutally scarred by these
bullies back then Shoji did explain to
his fellow mutant type Quirk users like
Koda and tokoyami that their experience
is different from his because they came
from cities there are still places out
there where people would go so far as to
eliminate heteromorph children in the
name of some misguided idea of Purity
Shoji's classmates are visibly upset
when they learn about all the hardships
that he had to go through and minata
apologizes for calling Shoji an octopus
earlier on in the story but Shoji says
it's all good he even chose tentacle as
his hero name and he enjoys stuff like
the most villain looking Hero rankings
so Shoji doesn't take himself or his
appear parents too seriously he doesn't
see himself as a victim and he is just
an incredibly strong and impressive
person the fact that he is a heteromorph
and the scars that he carries with him
have given Shoji a very specific Mission
and that mission is to become a Great
Hero and help his fellow mutant type
Quirk users while also proving to the
world that heteromorphs can be amazing
Heroes just like everyone else the
reason he wore his mask wasn't because
he was ashamed of his appearance it was
because he didn't want people to think
he was a villain or that he was out for
Retribution tokuyami calls this true
strength and honestly I couldn't agree
more Shoji is an absolute Chad and a
true hero man I really wish that we got
to know more about Shoji sooner because
he's quickly becoming one of my favorite
characters based on the last few
chapters alone Shoji reiterates that yes
he has a lot of painful memories from
his childhood and he will never forget
them but instead of dwelling on that
that he chooses to focus on the positive
one time when he was still a kid he was
able to save a little girl from a raging
water current but he was only able to
save her because of the unique
composition of his body if he had had a
so-called normal human body he would not
have been able to save her and the
little girl would have drowned in that
moment Shoji was overjoyed to have the
exact body type that he does and this is
what he chooses to focus on whenever he
is feeling down about his situation and
wow that is powerful and that really is
true strength mad respect to Shoji at
that point Shoji's classmates rushed to
him and hug him and he Embraces all of
them with his many arms they all vowed
to make a ton of happy memories together
from now on and even though Shoji
doesn't believe that a century of
prejudice will come to an end any time
in their lifetimes he still wants to do
his best to continue you the good fight
and to carry the torch for people who
came before him he wants to become the
world's coolest hero he wants to become
a role model for all heteromorphs and he
wants to pass this good memory on to the
next Generation that is Shoji's Mission
back in the present Shoji manages to
recover from Spinner's attack and he
continues to fight on Bravely against
the massive scaly and completely berserk
monster that spinner has become despite
suffering oppression himself and despite
being aware that oppression against
heteromorphs still exists as we saw with
the giant furry girl who wasn't allowed
inside a shelter Shoji still knows that
more violence and more hatred is not the
answer the answer is doing what Deku did
helping the giant girl and everyone else
who needs it because that is what real
heroes do spinner obviously isn't
capable of processing any of this and he
just attacks wildly and the plf
commander tries to make Shoji's argument
look bad by mocking him and calling him
a heteromorph who was domesticated by
quote unquote humans but that is when
Coda steps in Furious that someone would
mock his friend Shoji Koda sends an
entire swarm of birds at the commander
and we see that the spikes on his head
are actually beginning to grow I don't
recall ever seeing this before so this
could be an indication that Coda is
about to show us a brand new power
meanwhile as Shoji morphs his
tentacle-like arms in preparation for an
attack on spinner spinner actually calls
him disgusting but Shoji doesn't care he
simply exclaims what can I say it's just
who I am as he prepares to throw a
massive punch directly at spinner and
that is how the chapter ends I've said
this a few times already but Shoji is
such a great character he has a
compelling and heartbreaking backstory
his entire life story is truly
inspirational he is a badass hero and he
is a super wholesome homie I know that
mha has a big cast and you can't give
equal time to everyone but knowing what
we know now about Shoji I really do wish
we got to know him better sooner but it
is what it is it's obvious that these
past few chapters have really emphasized
the plight of the heteromorphs aka the
mutant type Quirk users for whatever
reason horikoshi really wants us to
understand their struggle at this late
stage in the story it is so important to
him that he was willing to move the
action away from the three massive
battles that are currently raging in
order to spend time on this and that got
me thinking there could be a bigger
reason why this exact topic is being
explored so extensively right now at the
end of the story it could be connected
to the last big mystery that mha still
hasn't revealed even though horikoshi
said that it would be revealed by the
end and I am of course referring to the
true identity of deku's Father since the
very beginning we've all been wondering
who deku's father is and why he's never
around even though he is apparently
alive and well and even though he and
inko are apparently still married Deku
and his mother don't seem to have any
sort of active relationship with deku's
Dad at least from what we've been able
to see based on what horikoshi has shown
us we know that deku's Dad has a fire
breathing Quirk and that he apparently
works abroad but that's about it but
what if the mysterious Hisashi midorias
fire breathing Quirk is not just a fire
breathing Quirk what if he actually has
a mutant type Quirk that turns his
entire body either fiery or extremely
hot and this makes him dangerous to be
around maybe his Quirk started out as
fire breathing but then it awakened or
revolved over time or maybe inko just
didn't tell us the full story but if
deku's Dad had a mutant type Quirk that
cannot be turned off and that could make
him a danger to the people around him
because of the fiery properties of his
Quirk then that would actually explain
why he has been absent from Deku and
inko's life he says she may believe that
staying as far away from his family as
possible is the best thing for them this
could be because he doesn't want them to
face discrimination due to the fact that
he is a heteromorph or it could be
because the true nature of his Quirk
makes him actually dangerous to be
around or it could be a combination of
those two factors honestly an
explanation along these lines is one of
the very few explanations that would
actually make sense why would a father
stay away from his family for years and
yet the family doesn't feel that he
abandoned them and they don't have any
animosity towards him it could be
because he is staying away for their own
safety and they might be aware of that
the CIA seen from the previous chapter
where someone who looks a lot like all
for one from behind is attacking and
murdering heteromorphs could also play a
part in this all for one may have a
connection to deku's father and so once
deku's father does make his appearance
it will be directly connected to the
final battle against all for one it's
hard to say what exactly that connection
would be and there are a lot of people
who believe that all for one is in fact
deku's dad but there are other
intriguing possibilities like deku's
father being one of the heteromorphs
whom all for one tried to kill or deku's
father approaching all for one for a
favor after Deku was born for example if
we accept that Hisashi has a quirk that
could make him a danger to others and if
Deku was born with that same type of
work then perhaps Hisashi approached all
for one anujiko in order to somehow
remove deku's Quirk before it evolved
into something dangerous so Deku may
have been born with a quirk but it was
taken from him for his own safety but in
order to get the Quirk removed deku's
father was forced to make a deal with
the devil and now he has to keep his
distance partially because of his own
Quirk and partially because of the
dangerous deal that he made with the
villains this is all speculation of
course but it's definitely intriguing to
speculate about deku's Father's true
identity I mean for all we know if he
really is a heteromorph he might have
already been shown on screen at some
point in the manga but we just didn't
recognize him definitely let me know
down in the comments who you think
deku's father is and why do you think
that he has been completely absent for
all this time and why don't Deku and
inko seem to be upset at all by his long
absence also how freaking awesome is
meso Shoji don't forget to leave your
feedback down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more mha content here on the channel
leave a quick like and comment and if
you're one of the over 50 percent of
people who hasn't subscribed yet do me a
big favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications you
can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar big thank you
to all of our anime outpro patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to trucker Tim a
disciple of Lord twigo himself and I
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons including Alpha Sigma Pate heffa
The Toasted Qi Cory McGowan own Taylor
and Anime s code M finally thank you to
all of our other patrons including Pro
Hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh Angel Cruz Alicia Octor fat
boy games kaido might be a duck alivenia
Sandy and the school bus if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon or by becoming a channel
member as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys